um dominic cummings today still
wanting people to follow him two weeks
ago he suggested excoriating questions
for the latest pandemic lessons learnt
session with mps
all to be bold at the health secretary
in another attempt to get him out of the
job
is it your chance to give the version of
events today mr hancock the session
turned out to be less explosive
but more important than it had been
built
he began by rattling through denials of
the specifics put to the committee two
weeks ago
of lying including to boris johnson did
you ever
say anything to the prime minister that
you knew not to be true
no today mattered because matt hancock
discussed not
whether things went wrong but why the
hell secretary appeared to accept the
government locked down later than it
might have done
but stressed he personally was across
the scale of the challenge
as early as january last year i was
given the planning assumption
based on spanish flu and
it was signed off at cobra on the 31st
of january
and that was a planning assumption for
820
000 deaths and i was determined that
that
would not happen on my watch mps in the
inquiry today
told us what their conclusions are going
to be they think we locked down too late
last march there wasn't enough testing
early on
and they're probably going to find that
we shouldn't have sent patients from
hospitals direct to care homes
what was interesting though was matt
hancock didn't reject those findings
instead he tried to give context
background even
shape who people should think got the
blame
one of the major charges leveled at
ministers is that care homes were
deluged with patients with coronavirus
direct from hospitals
matt hancock said that he was so
concerned that those without symptoms
might be ill
that he put in calls all over the world
to find out more
i was so worried about it i arranged a
call with the world health organization
and i was told
on that call that with respect to china
this was a
likely a mis a mistranslation
i bitterly regret that i didn't overrule
that
scientific advice at the start and say
we should proceed on the basis that
there is asymptomatic transmission
the global scientific consensus might
have been wrong but the uk's own
government scientists warned in january
that they had found limited evidence of
asymptomatic transmission
care home staff also complained to sky
news that they lacked
personal protective equipment ppe but
today the health secretary said
despite local challenges and i don't
deny at all there were there were
challenges in individual areas
there was never a national shortage of
ppe because of the action that
we took and yet a report into ppe by the
government's own watchdog
found many frontline workers in health
and adult social care reporting
not having access to the ppe they needed
during the height of the shortages
learning lessons to avoid more scenes
like this
but key players still very careful to
make sure the finger of blame
doesn't point at them sam coates sky
news